I mean, std shuffle got removed, so. No, random shuffle got removed. No, random shuffle got removed. Oh, man. Std shuffle's the replacement. You just got owned, my friend. You're listening to three algorithm experts, clearly one of which is less of an algorithm expert than the other two.
我的意思是，std shuffle 被删除了，所以。不对，random shuffle 被删除了。不对，random shuffle 被删除了。天哪。Std shuffle 是替代品。你被碾压了，我的朋友。你在收听三个算法专家，其中显然有一个算法专家不如另外两个。
Boom. Boom. welcome to adsb the podcast episode 77 recorded on april 19th 2022 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we continue part three of our four-part interview with ben dean talking Ben Dean talking about C++ algorithms. Yeah, we should move on to the profiling because Bryce is, I'm fading fast. It's approaching my bedtime. I don't know how you're still alive given that you exercised more than me today.
砰。砰。欢迎来到 adbs 播客第 77 期，录制于 2022 年 4 月 19 日，我叫康纳，今天与我的联合主持布莱斯一起，我们继续进行对本·迪恩关于 C++ 算法的四部分访谈的第三部分。是的，我们应该转到性能分析（profiling），因为布莱斯，我快坚持不住了。快到我的睡觉时间了。鉴于你今天锻炼得比我还多，我不知道你怎么还活着。
I'm wired. I'm wired. I mean, we're talking about birds, combinators. The crash hasn't happened yet. It's coming. It's coming. I mean, you also have a way earlier bedtime than me you know i typically go to sleep at like midnight my bedtime has been disrupted the entire winter not entirely because of winter but because of my bring up the profiling make bryce nice and angry so he stays awake. There are things wrong here, Bryce. All right. There's no,
我处于亢奋状态。我处于亢奋状态。我的意思是，我们在谈论小鸟、组合子。崩溃还没发生呢。它要来了。它要来了。我的意思是，你的睡觉时间也比我早得多，你知道我通常在午夜左右睡觉，我的作息整个冬天都被打乱了，不完全是因为冬天，而是因为我的……谈谈性能分析，让布莱斯高兴又生气，这样他就能保持清醒了。这里有些不对劲，布莱斯。好吧。这里没有，
there's no, there's no error bars. So, you know, it's using quick bench. All right. Whatever. I,
这里没有，这里没有误差条。所以，你知道的，它使用的是 quick bench。好吧。随便吧。我，
I have, I have, there is no, there is nothing in this graph that tells me anything about the measurement uncertainty. So I have no idea whether or not I can trust these numbers. So first of all, let's do a tiny bit better job. The tweet that we are looking at is the first photo that Tyler tweeted out, and it's profiling five different solutions, sort, nth element, max element,
我有，我有，没有，这个图表中没有任何东西能告诉我关于测量不确定性的任何信息。所以我完全不知道我是否可以信任这些数字。首先，让我们做得稍微好一点。我们正在看的这条推文是泰勒发出的第一张照片，它对五种不同的解决方案进行了性能分析：sort、nth element、max element、
std reduce, and and stood transform reduce and in order or would you like to say something now bryce this is like not even a graph like you gotta you gotta you gotta label both axes no i look like tyler you've done great work you've done great work. You've done great work. But here are my notes. What's the y-axis? I think it's just a relative measure. I don't even think it necessarily needs to have all this stuff. I agree. These are notes, I think, less for Tyler and more for...
std reduce 和 std transform reduce，按顺序，或者你现在想说点什么吗，布莱斯？这甚至都不像是一个图表，你得把两个坐标轴都标上标签。不，我觉得很好，泰勒，你干得太棒了，你干得太棒了。你干得太棒了。但这是我的笔记。Y 轴是什么？我想这只是一个相对度量。我甚至不认为它必须包含所有这些东西。我同意。我想这些笔记与其说是给泰勒看的，不如说是给……
But if it's a relative measure, then you need to say what it's scaled to. Well, as a relative measure, we should say... I mean, some things we can say. Yeah, no, wait, wait. This is 100% not Tyler's fault. This is whoever writes for him. Isn't it... I don't want to say... I feel bad if I'm giving the wrong
但如果它是一个相对度量，那么你需要说明它是按什么比例缩放的。好吧，作为一种相对度量，我们应该说……我的意思是，有些事情我们可以说。是的，不，等等，等等。这百分之百不是泰勒的错。这是为他写东西的人的错。这不是……我不想说……如果我给错了功劳，我会感到难过的。
credit. But is it Fred? Yeah, yeah. Fred, you're coming on the podcast i have i have some constraints like probably how much computation time fred wants to pay for for the site to devote to this kind of thing but no no no this is nothing about computation time like this is basic best practices of statistical performance analysis um okay all right let's look at the actual code for what for what's uh what's being done here well so first we should i mean for the for the individual the listener that is not going to go and look at this yeah from worst to best uh the sort is the worsting it, it's about twice as bad as the next.
但那是弗雷德吗？对，对。弗雷德，你要上播客了，我有一些限制，比如弗雷德可能愿意为网站投入多少计算时间来做这种事情，但是不，不，不，这跟计算时间一点关系都没有，这是统计性能分析的基本最佳实践。嗯，好吧，让我们看看实际的代码，看看这里正在做什么。好吧，首先我们应该——对于不会去查看这个的个别听众——从最差到最好，sort 是最差的，大约是下一个的两倍差。
Now, the bottom of this graph says lower is faster. And any time that you produce a graph where you have to explain something that should be intuitive, that typically means that something has gone wrong. Instead of saying lower is faster, why don't you just change your visualization so that higher is faster, which is the intuitive reading of graphs. Oh, well, actually, look here. We do have the X and Y axis. They're just not labeled on the X and Y axis. It's CPU time.
现在，这个图表的底部写着“越低越快”。任何时候，当你制作一个图表时，如果必须解释一个本应直观的概念，这通常意味着出了问题。与其说“越低越快”，为什么不直接改变你的可视化方式，让“更高更快”成为对图表的直观解读呢？哦，好吧，其实，看这里。我们有 X 轴和 Y 轴。只是 X 轴和 Y 轴上没有标签。那是 CPU 时间。
Yes, I noticed that, but they should have been labeled on the axis. And also, what is CPU time? What is no op time okay what can we say that's useful here for the listener one is that um after the very low numbers basically all the graphs are linear um and sort is the outlier in terms of comparing the slopes of the graphs sort looks to be about about double the slope of the next highest, which is reduction. But interestingly, there's a data point at about 4K for all of these,
是的，我注意到了，但它们应该标在坐标轴上。而且，什么是 CPU 时间？什么是无操作（no op）时间？好吧，我们能为听众说点什么有用的？一是，在非常低的数字之后，基本上所有的图表都是线性的，而 sort 是个例外，如果比较图表的斜率，sort 的斜率似乎大约是下一个最高项（即 reduction）的两倍。但有趣的是，所有这些在 4K 左右都有一个数据点，
but there's no data point for 8k for two largest sort which is the the worst performing one and i assume that's because like it just took too long actually i thought now i never looked at that but now that you say that nth element is actually the fastest at uh is it or is it just the the painter's algorithm that's happened to put it in front? Yes. It looks because at this point, at the 1,000 mark, it looks like they're definitely overlapping. But on my screen, I can see a slight green above. Instead of inferring things from lines, why don't you look at numbers?
但对于最大的两个 sort 来说，没有 8K 的数据点，这是表现最差的，我猜那是因为它花了太长时间。其实，我想，现在我从来没看过那个，但既然你这么说，nth element 实际上是最快的，呃，是吗，还是这只是恰好把它放在前面的画家算法（painter's algorithm）？是的。看起来是因为在这个时候，在 1,000 的标记处，它们看起来绝对是重叠的。但在我的屏幕上，我可以看到上面有一点绿色。与其从线条中推断事情，你为什么不看看数字呢？
Because numbers don't lie, except for these numbers, because we don't have uncertainty bars. You can actually do that. Okay, quick benches. It is pretty cool that it does this in real time. What these numbers seem to say, if we can say anything, is that sort is definitely the slowest in all cases after the very small numbers. And maxElement, I assume that's just run maxElement, remove the found, and then run maxElement again. Seems to be marginally faster than the rest. Let me see the code for that.
因为数字不会说谎，除了这些数字，因为我们没有不确定性条。你其实可以做到这一点。好吧，quick benches。它能实时完成这个，这真是太酷了。如果我们要说点什么的话，这些数字似乎表明，在极小的数字之后，sort 在所有情况下绝对都是最慢的。而 maxElement，我猜那只是运行 maxElement，删除找到的元素，然后再次运行 maxElement。似乎比其余的要稍微快一点。让我看看那段代码。
Let's see the code for that. We'll look at the code in a sec um but so this is this we should note just to to finish this narrative this is for the original original uh solutions that tyler programmed but i responded to this because he was basically asking why is this the results and uh and that maybe you'll have because i i might be wrong about what i initially posted back to him you may have quote tweeted yeah so there's two different ones that i ended up doing so i i don't know why this is so small can i zoom in yeah so i programmed a accumulate which ended up being slightly faster than the max element. And then I also ended up finding my initial transform reduce, which is hard to see here,
让我们看看那段代码。我们一会儿就会看代码，嗯，但这——为了结束这个叙事，我们应该注意到，这是针对泰勒编写的最初的原始解决方案，但我对此进行了回应，因为他基本上是在问为什么结果会是这样，而且也许你会——因为我最初回复他的内容可能不对——你可能引用转发了（quote tweeted）……是的，所以我最终做了两种不同的。所以，我不知道为什么这个这么小，我可以放大吗？可以。所以我编写了一个 accumulate，结果比 maxElement 稍微快一点。然后我最终找到了我最初的 transform reduce，在这里很难看清楚，
but it's the purple that's underneath the green. So it's slightly faster than the accumulate. So now that we've said all that. Wait, why is yours? Okay, let's look at his first, and then let's look at yours. The code. I want to see code now.
但它是绿地底下的紫色。所以它比 accumulate 稍微快一点。既然我们已经说完了这些。等等，为什么你的……好吧，我们先看他的，然后看你的。代码。我现在想看代码。
Well, I think I included my QuickBench, and my QuickBench has all of the solutions. It's just that you can only run on the web version four of them at a time, which is why only four of them show up. Yeah, I want to see. So let me zoom in a tiny bit here because I'm sure this is not super. All right, I want to see his max element one first.
好吧，我想我包含了我的 QuickBench，我的 QuickBench 拥有所有的解决方案。只是你一次只能在网页版上运行其中的四个，这就是为什么只有四个显示出来。是的，我想看。所以我在这里稍微放大一点，因为我确信这不是超级……好吧，我想先看他的 max element 代码。
All right, so now we're doing live code review. Yes, we are doing live code review. We are doing live code review indeed. So he's not randomizing the input, right? No, it's just a modulus operation. You should probably try... Let me tell you from my experience benchmarking Cubs Radex sort implementation, you want to test with a few different input patterns for anything sorting or partial sorting related
好吧，所以现在我们正在进行实时代码审查。是的，我们正在进行实时代码审查。我们的确在进行实时代码审查。所以他没有对输入进行随机化，对吧？没有，这只是一个取模（modulus）操作。你可能应该尝试……根据我为 Cub 的 Radex 排序实现进行基准测试的经验，对于任何与排序或部分排序相关的任务，或者这一类的任何问题，你都想用几种不同的输入模式来进行测试。
or any problem of this class. Okay. Two larger sort, not surprised. Let me see the, I want to see the max element. This is the max element one he's erasing in the vector uh did we we didn't ever get unstable arrays did we yeah if the things aren't sorted you might as well swap it with the last element or well well okay so so i wouldn't i actually wouldn't erase i would just uh i would just change it to not be the largest that's going to be faster you don't have to actually remove the element and move other things yeah try try instead instead of doing the erase there, try just changing it to be zero and then rerun it.
好的。两个更大的 sort，毫不意外。让我看看，我想看 max element。这是 max element 的一个，他在 vector 中擦除（erasing）——我们从来没有遇到过不稳定的数组，对吧？是的，如果这些东西没有排序，你大可以将它与最后一个元素交换，或者……好吧，好吧，所以——我其实不会去擦除（erase），我只会——我只会把它改成不是最大值，那样会更快，你实际上不必移除元素并移动其他东西。是的，尝试——尝试不要在那里做 erase，尝试把它改成零，然后重新运行它。
I want to see what happens. All right. We're doing live coding, which we said we wouldn't do. I believe we have been explicitly requested to not do this anymore. But you know what? It's a programming podcast. And let's get rid of...
我想看看会发生什么。好吧。我们正在进行现场编码，而我们说过我们不会这么做。我相信我们曾被明确要求不要再这样做了。但你知道吗？这是一个编程播客。让我们摆脱……
Because right now the ones we're profiling are the max element, my accumulate, my transform reduce and then Tyler's transform reduce. But Tyler's transform reduce is a lot slower than mine. Because I think it's because he's using a sort. I mean, slightly less destructively if you're worried about that,
因为现在我们正在进行性能分析的是 max element、我的 accumulate、我的 transform reduce，然后是泰勒的 transform reduce。但泰勒的 transform reduce 比我的慢得多。因为我认为这是因为他在使用 sort。我的意思是，如果你担心这一点，破坏性稍微小一点的做法，
is just to do an iter swap with the end minus one and then run your max element on the end minus one. Ah, that's very clever. An iter swap on the largest iterator in what iterator? The prev of the end. end yes that's very clever now we're cooking now we're cooking oh yeah that is nice that is nice if this proves to be the fastest way to do this it's's ridiculous, Max. I mean, a swap is doing a bit more work than just setting it to zero, admittedly, but it's slightly less destructive.
就是对 end 减 1 执行 iter swap，然后在 end 减 1 上运行你的 max element。啊，这太聪明了。对最大迭代器执行 iter swap，是什么迭代器？end 的前一个（prev）。end，是的，这太聪明了。现在我们渐入佳境了。现在我们渐入佳境了。哦，是的，这很好，这很好。如果事实证明这是做到这一点的最快方法，那就太荒谬了，Max。我的意思是，诚然，swap 所做的工作比将其设置为零要多一点，但它的破坏性要小一些。
It's a difference of complexity class. And this is the same as doing the assignment. All right, this is going to take potentially 30 seconds or 60 seconds okay so then while that's happening i want to see his transform reduce and understand why it's we uh we made a compilation error list to your listener so is this swap defined if you pass it the same iterator twice? I do not know the answer to that question. Let's find out.
这是复杂度级别的差异。这与进行赋值是一样的。好吧，这可能需要 30 秒或 60 秒。好吧，所以在发生这种情况的同时，我想看看他的 transform reduce，并了解为什么它——我们给你的听众造成了编译错误列表——那么如果把相同的迭代器传给它两次，这个 swap 是有定义的吗？我不知道这个问题的答案。让我们找找看。
I mean, because if you do that, I guess no matter what it does, it might trash that element because it might do a move assignment to self or something, but not in the case of integers. But getting the second largest element will still work because you'll just do n minus 1. All right, so let's look at his reduce. So his transform reduce, is that actually? I'm going to zoom out a tiny bit just so you can see more of this.
我的意思是，因为如果你这样做，我猜无论它做什么，它都可能会破坏那个元素，因为它可能会对自身执行移动赋值（move assignment）之类的操作，但在整数的情况下不会。但获取第二大的元素仍然有效，因为你只需执行 n 减 1。好吧，让我们看看他的 reduce。所以他的 transform reduce，真的是那样吗？我要稍微缩小一点，这样你就能看到更多这个。
Is that OK? You can still read this? What? What? What? What? What? What? of this is that okay you can still read this what what what what what embrace having problems reading no no i think i i'm just trying i think why are we so
这样可以吗？你还能读懂吗？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？什么？这样可以吗？你还能读懂吗？什么？什么？什么？什么？而布莱斯在阅读时遇到了麻烦。不，不，我想我——我只是在想，为什么我们这么……
so that's he did mention in his video he's not sure if there's a better way to do this if we compare it to the way i did it, I just used structured bindings and then did actually all of the, you know, cases. Yours makes more sense. It is a bit laborious to write out those four different cases, like admittedly. No, I actually, I kind of, I'm kind of liking his approach of basically he makes an array with um the left hand side and the right hand side and then he does a sort of that array so the profiling is done sorry to the listener for hopping around but um the max element is still slower than both the really what we need to do is we need we need to compare we need to compare the before and after of the max element.
所以这是他在视频中提到的，他不确定是否有更好的方法来做到这一点。如果我们把它和我做的方法进行比较，我只是使用了结构化绑定（structured bindings），然后实际上做了所有的……你知道的，各种情况。你的更有意义。诚然，写出这四种不同的情况有点费劲。不，其实，我有点——我有点喜欢他的方法，基本上他用左侧和右侧制作了一个数组，然后对该数组进行 sort。所以性能分析已经完成了——对不起，听众朋友，我们要跳来跳去——但是 max element 仍然比这两个都慢。实际上我们真正需要做的是，我们需要比较——我们需要比较 max element 的前后变化。
Would you like me to do that? Correct. That's easy enough to do. Just copy and paste. I do have a feeling that in this case it may not matter much because... Well, no, it really, I mean... So we'll call this 2 and what we had before
你希望我这么做吗？对。这很容易做到。只需复制并粘贴。我有一种感觉，在这种情况下，这可能并不重要，因为……好吧，不，真的，我的意思是……所以我们把这个叫作 2，而我们之前有的是
was vec dot erase largest it and then How large is n? Oh no, n is very bad. It's 10,000. I'm worried about the seed sequence in that.
vec dot erase largest it，然后 n 有多大？哦，不，n 非常糟糕。它是 10,000。我担心那里的种子序列（seed sequence）。
We're going to copy and paste this, and we're going to call 2 there. We're going to call 2 here. So 2 is the original, which doesn't make any sense but we're just hacking modulo zero can you show me can you show me the initialization code again yep so we're running now hopefully i got that right um see some compilers in a second here oh no times the input modulo 1000 favorite algorithm
我们要复制并粘贴这个，我们把那里叫作 2。我们在这里叫作 2。所以 2 是最初的那个，这没有任何意义，但我们只是在进行修改。对零取模（modulo zero）你能再给我看看初始化代码吗？是的，所以我们现在正在运行，希望我没有弄错，嗯，一会儿看一些编译器。哦，不，输入乘以 1000 对取模。最喜欢的算法
Ben while you're on the podcast did we ask you that last time I'm not sure favorite algorithm well two questions favorite algorithm in the standard and then outside the standard as well if you want uh algorithm in the standard and then outside the standard as well if you want uh
本，趁你在播客上，我们上次问过你那个问题吗？我不确定。最喜欢的算法，嗯，标准库中的最喜欢的算法，如果愿意的话，还有标准库之外的算法？标准库中的算法，如果愿意的话，还有标准库之外的算法？
that's really difficult to answer oh i i thought you were gonna say the name of your guinea pig i thought that honest i thought it was yeah is that i was gonna say yeah well i it's a special place in your heart min element wait you you have a guinea pig that you gave the name min element yeah min for short she's the largest of my pigs now she was when we got her she was tiny and now she's like three times the size it's a self-fulfilling prophecy right there let's see yeah i like uh what did i say i iota's good i like a bunch of them partition is good how is reduce not your answer how is reduce not my answer well for the same reason that you know reduces an algorithmic atom right it's not it's not i don't view it as the name of an algorithm at a at an application
这真的很难回答。哦，我还以为你要说你那只豚鼠的名字呢。说实话，我以为那是……是吗？我要说的是……是的，你在心中为它保留了一个特殊的位置。min element。等等，你有一只豚鼠，你给它起名叫 min element？是的，简称 min。它现在是我所有猪里最大的。我们得到它时它很小，现在它大约是三倍大。这正是一个自我实现的预言。让我们看看。是的，我喜欢……我刚才说什么来着？iota 不错，我喜欢其中的一部分。partition 不错。reduce 怎么就不是你的答案了？reduce 怎么就不是你的答案了？嗯，原因和你知道的相同，reduce 是一个算法原子（algorithmic atom），对吧？它不是——它不是——我不认为它在应用层面上是一个算法的名字。
level sometimes it is but often it's just the way an algorithm is implemented sort of thing there's a there's a question i mean not to interject this question that we're already giving you but is um what do you think about uh oh yeah we haven't even i've totally forgot about our heap um the the difference between calling things algorithms and functions i get a lot of flack sometimes from the array community for calling primitives algorithms they're like it's a primitive it's not an algorithm but like unique is a primitive and partitions a primitive and a bunch of things that we think of as algorithms in c++ are primitives in APL. So they think of it as if it's spellable with a single character
有时是这样，但通常它只是一种实现算法的方式，诸如此类。这里有一个问题——并不是要打断我们已经抛给你的这个问题——那就是，你对……哦，对了，我们甚至还没——我完全忘了我们的堆（heap），把事情叫作算法和函数之间的区别。数组社区有时会因为我把原语（primitives）称为算法而对我颇有微词。他们会说，这是一个原语，不是算法。但像 unique 是一个原语，partition 是一个原语，我们在 C++ 中认为是算法的一堆东西，在 APL 中都是原语。所以他们认为，如果它可以用单个字符拼写，
and it's a primitive, that's not an algorithm. That's a tool. That's a function that you use for building up algorithms. But I don't know, interested to get your thoughts. I suppose it's just a matter of where your head's at. You know, I think in C++, we tend to think of algorithms as things that work on sequences.
而且它是一个原语，那这就不是算法。这是一个工具。它是你用来构建算法的函数。但我不清楚，很有兴趣听听你的想法。我想这只取决于你的思维方式。你知道，我认为在 C++ 中，我们倾向于将算法视为对序列进行操作的东西。
If you view a sequence as a value, if you're working in an array language, then an array is a value to you. And so I can see how it'd be normal to think of what we think of as algorithms as functions. Interesting. It's context dependent, well at least i that
如果你将序列视为一个值，如果你使用的是数组语言，那么数组对你来说就是一个值。所以我可以理解为什么把我们认为是算法的东西看作函数会是很自然的事。有趣。这取决于上下文，至少我觉得
seems plausible i'm not trying to say this is how people think i'm somewhat potentially i'm somewhat concerned about um uh the initialization sequence that he's using because one of the the this like this sequence of modulos that he's doing um the the the maximum that any of these values is going to get is going to be 10 000 um uh because he's moduling by it. And using this initialization sequence regardless of input size, like the 60th element or so of this sequence is almost always going to be one of the answers. While we're live coding,
这似乎是合理的。我并不是想说这就是人们的想法。我有点——潜在地——对……嗯，他使用的初始化序列感到有点担忧，因为他正在做的这一系列取模操作中，这些值中任何一个能达到的最大值将是 10,000，因为他是对其进行取模。而且无论输入大小如何，都使用这个初始化序列，比如这个序列的大约第 60 个元素几乎总是会是答案之一。在我们进行现场编码的同时，
we should probably change this to, you know, to use... Right, right. We're not going to implement Mersenne Twister. You can include random. I mean, if you spell it out for me, maybe I'll type it. But just while, before we do that, so we have gotten back the results for our two different max element solutions. And definitely the max element that does an iter swap with the last element and then does a max element up until the second last element inclusive is slower, is faster, faster sorry in all cases than the original one um and actually interestingly um that max element so previously it went
我们可能应该把这个改成，你知道的，使用……对，对。我们不会去实现梅森旋转算法（Mersenne Twister）。你可以 include random。我的意思是，如果你为我拼写出来，也许我会敲键盘。但就在——在我们做这件事之前，我们已经拿回了我们两个不同的 max element 解决方案的结果。毫无疑问，与最后一个元素进行 iter swap，然后对直到倒数第二个元素（含）执行 max element 的那个 max element，在所有情况下都比最初的那个更慢——更快，抱歉，更快——而且有趣的是，那个 max element——所以之前它是
max elements that was doing the erase then the transform reduce that i implemented and then the accumulate that i implemented and accumulate that i implemented is the fastest by far, or I shouldn't say by far in all cases. Um, but now the max element that does the inner swap, uh, is actually basic. I won't say faster. It's slightly faster and slightly slower. So we'll just call it the same as the, my, uh, the transform reduced that I wrote. So interesting. Um, and while, before we go and change the data here, one of the reduce that I wrote. So interesting. And while before we go and change the data here, one of the things that I had said to, I actually don't need to bring up the tweet that I'd said to Tyler initially, when he was seeing the transform reduce was slower is that he had done all that building up of the operators for the function objects and had the four overloads.
执行 erase 的 max element，然后是我实现的 transform reduce，然后是我实现的 accumulate，而我实现的 accumulate 远比它们快，或者我不应该说在所有情况下都远比它们快。嗯，但现在，执行 iter swap 的 max element 实际上基本上——我不会说更快。它稍微快一点，也稍微慢一点。所以我们姑且认为它和我写的 transform reduce 是一样的。所以很有趣。嗯，而且在我们去修改这里的数据之前，我之前对——其实我不需要调出我最初对泰勒说的推文，当他看到 transform reduce 更慢时，他为函数对象构建了所有的运算符，并且有四个重载。
And I said, without calling, calling you know stood reduced with the execution policy so that it's in parallel you're sort of doing all that work for nothing um but like one if you call stood reduced with a non-commutative and associative operator but don't pass an execution policy it's it's still like broken correct you always have to do that is that the case or is the non-execution policy version you can think of it as like a fold i think it's still broken because i think commutativity is required for vectorization i believe even without the i wasn't parallelism sorry i wasn't paying attention because I was writing the initialization code.
我说，如果不调用——调用，你知道的，带执行策略（execution policy）的 std reduce 以使其并行，你这样做基本上是白费力气。但就像——如果你调用带非交换和非结合运算符但未传递执行策略的 std reduce，它仍然是——损坏的，对吧？你总是必须这样做是这样吗，还是非执行策略版本——你可以把它想象成一个折叠（fold），我认为它仍然是损坏的，因为我认为向量化（vectorization）需要交换律（commutativity），我相信即使没有——我不是指并行性，抱歉，我刚才没注意，因为我在写初始化代码。
That's what I thought, Ben. The question, Bryce, was... Can you repeat the question? Reduce has a few overloads. There's the execution policy, parallelizable one. There's one without execution policy. Does the commutative constraint apply to both or only to the parallel ones? Yes, it applies to the non-parallel ones.
我是这么认为的，本。布莱斯，这个问题是……你能重复一下这个问题吗？Reduce 有几个重载。有一个执行策略、可并行的版本。有一个没有执行策略的版本。交换律约束适用于两者，还是仅适用于并行版本？是的，它适用于非并行版本。
And if you look at how it's implemented in GCC's standard library, they actually take advantage of this, of the fact that they know that it's non-communitative to do a few fewer operations. That basically like each pass of the loop, they'll do like two reductions and then they'll add them together. And so it will actually break. Essentially, it's a little bit of like, you know, loop on manual loop unrolling. And it's a good optimization, I think. Wait, so you said it because it's non little bit of like you know loop on manual loop unrolling um uh and it's a good optimization
如果你看看它在 GCC 标准库中的实现方式，他们实际上利用了这一点，利用他们知道它是非交换的这一事实来减少一些操作。基本上就像循环的每次迭代中，他们会做两次 reduction，然后把它们加在一起。所以它实际上会崩溃。本质上，这有点像——你知道的，手动循环展开（manual loop unrolling）。我认为这是一个很好的优化。等等，所以你刚才说——因为它不是——有点像——你知道的，手动循环展开，嗯——而且这是一个很好的优化，
i think um wait so you said you said it because it's non-communitive but i think you meant community yeah yes that that's that's what i meant um but what i meant really was it will break from for things that are non-communitive connor i sent you the initialization or a snippet of of how it's very easy to to like to to do this initialization using the std shuffle. It's super easy. It's one line. I mean, std shuffle got removed. No.
我认为——等等，所以你刚才说，因为它是非交换的，但我想你指的是交换的。对，对，那就是我所意思的，但我真正想说的是，对于非交换的东西，它会崩溃。康纳，我发给你了初始化代码，或者一个代码片段，展示了使用 std shuffle 进行这种初始化是多么容易。超级简单。它只有一行。我的意思是，std shuffle 被删除了。不。
Random shuffle got removed. Std shuffle is the replacement. That's what happens. You're listening to three algorithm experts, clearly one of which is less of an algorithm expert than the other two. At least when it comes to the topic of the shuffle algorithms. Go to Twitter.
Random shuffle 被删除了。Std shuffle 是替代品。事情就是这样。你在收听三个算法专家，其中显然有一个算法专家不如另外两个。至少在 shuffle 算法这个话题上是这样。去 Twitter。
I sent you the code. Just wait. Let's finish this topic, though, because what I told Tyler is that basically all of that work of building up that function object, if not parallelizing it, is sort of a waste. But that's totally wrong because you need to do that no matter what. Otherwise, it's totally wrong because you need to do that no matter what, otherwise it's broken. And it shouldn't really be the case that that is slowing down the, like, would you, or so here's the question, because what we're staring at right now is a stood accumulate that's faster than a transform reduce. So if you aren't using parallelization, is it the case that stood accumulate a left fold or fold left is going to be in many times faster when you don't have a simple associative binary, commutative and associative binary operation like plus because then you have to go and build up a function object?
我把代码发给你了。等一下。不过，让我们结束这个话题，因为我告诉泰勒的是，如果不进行并行化，构建该函数对象的所有工作基本上都是一种浪费。但这是完全错误的，因为无论如何你都必须这样做。否则，这是完全错误的，因为无论如何你都必须这样做，否则代码就损坏了。而且那真的不应该拖慢——比如，你会——或者这里有个问题，因为我们现在正盯着一个比 transform reduce 更快的 std accumulate。所以如果你不使用并行化，当你没有像加法这样简单的结合二元、交换和结合二元运算时，std accumulate（一个左折叠或 fold left）会在很多情况下更快吗？因为那样你就必须去构建一个函数对象。
So like is it that really you should only be reaching for std reduce if you are able to parallelize it? Otherwise, you're just going to be slowing your code down? Is that like a universally true thing? No, no, no. I mean, std reduce, like, if you have an operation that's commutative and associative, you should be using std reduce because your implementation can take advantage of it. Here's what I'm showing you what GCC's standard library,
所以——真的是只有当你能够对其进行并行化时，你才应该使用 std reduce 吗？否则，你只会把你的代码拖慢？这就像是一个普遍真理吗？不，不，不。我的意思是，std reduce，如果你有一个满足交换律和结合律的操作，你应该使用 std reduce，因为你的实现可以利用这一点。下面我向你展示 GCC 的标准库中，
std reduce, does here. And inside of the while loop that it does, so it does the while loop, it does one while loop where it does four elements in each iteration. So sort of vectorized, if you will. And then it has a finalization loop that takes care of any remainder.
std reduce 是怎么做的。在它执行的 while 循环内部——所以它执行 while 循环，它执行一个 while 循环，在每次迭代中处理四个元素。所以，如果你愿意的话，可以说是某种程度的向量化。然后它有一个处理任何余数的收尾循环（finalization loop）。
And so it does, within each iteration of this loop that does four elements, it does the binary op on the zeroth and oneth element. Then it does the binary op on the second and third element. And then it does a binary op
因此，在这个处理四个元素的循环的每次迭代中，它对第零个和第一个元素执行二元运算。然后它对第二个和第三个元素执行二元运算。然后它对
on those two intermediate results here. And so this one does some loop unrolling and two, it saves you some operations. And it gives you some vectorization potential. I don't think this is requiring commutativity though from what I'm reading here. It's requiring associativity. Yes, yes. So, yeah, yeah.
这两个中间结果执行二元运算。因此，这里做了一些循环展开，第二，它为你节省了一些操作。并为你带来了一些向量化潜力。不过，根据我在这里读到的内容，这似乎并不要求交换律。它要求的是结合律。是的，是的。所以，对，对。
Yes, but this is just one example of how an implementation could optimize this. Another way that an implementation could optimize this would be to do vectorization inside this loop. And that would require the commutativity. would be to do vectorization inside this loop. And that would require the commutativity. But this is just a demonstration of one such optimization that this allows, and that's actually done in the wild. There's other, you could also use that information to do the vectorization.
是的，但这只是实现如何优化这一点的一个例子。实现可以优化这一点的另一种方法是在这个循环内部进行向量化。那将需要交换律。——将在这个循环内部进行向量化。那将需要交换律。但这只是这种优化所允许的一个示范，并且这在实际中确实得到了应用。还有其他——你也可以利用该信息来进行向量化。
Well, if you're really being standards conforming, you couldn't like always like say like, hey, we'll always vectorize this loop. But you could give a hint to the compiler because to actually do the vectorization requires some additional C++ standard blessing. But an implementation could choose to do these, like to do, it doesn't have to do these in like the order here. It could choose to do a binary op on first, on the zero with element in the third element, and then the first element in
好吧，如果你真的要完全符合标准，你就不能总是——比如说，“嘿，我们总是会向量化这个循环”。但你可以给编译器一个提示，因为要实际进行向量化需要一些额外的 C++ 标准许可。但实现可以选择这样做——比如这样做，它不必像这里的顺序那样执行这些操作。如果它愿意的话，它可以选择对第一个、第零个元素和第三个元素，然后对第一个元素和
the second element if it's so chose i mean not that there's like a particularly good reason to do that but you could do it if you wanted so i mean what i'm sort of thinking here is that um if you have just an array of floats um with this implementation accumulate could well give a different answer to reduce yes that is correct that is correct and actually i think one of the reasons why so i'm sure that the gcc implementation did this because it gives you know some performance benefit and fewer evaluations but another good reason to do this is that it it breaks the code of anybody that yeah that makes the wrong assumptions about reduce, which is a nice thing. Okay.
第二个元素执行二元运算——当然，并没有什么特别好的理由去那样做，但如果你想的话，你可以这样做。所以——我的意思是，我在这里想到的是，如果你只有一个 float 数组，通过这种实现，accumulate 很可能会给出与 reduce 不同的答案。是的，这是正确的，这是正确的。事实上，我认为原因之一是——我确信 GCC 的实现这样做了，因为它带来了一些性能优势和更少的求值，但这样做的另一个好理由是，它会破坏任何人的代码——这些人对 reduce 做了错误假设，这倒是一件好事。好的。
All right. Connor, put in my initialization code. Let's rerun this thing. We'll do that in three minutes. So the question is then, maybe it's not because it's going to take three minutes to answer the question I'm about to ask. My favorite algorithm not in the standard. Oh, yeah. There are a couple of six minutes on the standard. Oh, yeah. Let's do that for six minutes on the clock.
好的。康纳，把我的初始化代码放进去。让我们重新运行这个。我们在三分钟内完成。所以问题是，也许不是，因为回答我接下来要问的问题需要三分钟。我最喜欢的算法不在标准库中。哦，是的。标准库中有几个，计时六分钟。哦，是的。我们在时钟上设定六分钟。
Candidates. One is HyperLogLog. Oh, great one. Yeah. There's someone from Facebook that has a talk about four different algorithms, and that's one of them. Fantastic algorithms and where to find them. CPCon 2017, I think. Can you re-say what the name was?
候选者。一个是 HyperLogLog。哦，太棒了。是的。Facebook 有个人做了一个关于四种不同算法的演讲，这就是其中之一。出色的算法以及在哪里找到它们。CppCon 2017，我想。你能再说一遍名字是什么吗？
Hyper Log Log. Hyper Log Log. Come on. Come on. I'm not processing. It's a probabilistic algorithm, right? The sort of poster child use case for it is counting unique logins, right?
Hyper Log Log。Hyper Log Log。拜托。拜托。我脑子没转过来。这是一个概率算法，对吧？它的典型用例是计算唯一登录数，对吧？
So you run a website. You have billions of logins over the course of a month. You want to know how many of them are unique. HyperLogLog allows you to estimate this in a probabilistic way. And like many probabilistic algorithms, it has the characteristic that you can spend either computation power or memory
所以你经营一个网站。在长达一个月的时间里，你有数十亿次的登录。你想知道其中有多少个是唯一的。HyperLogLog 允许你以概率的方式估计这一点。和许多概率算法一样，它具有这样一个特点：你可以花费计算能力或内存
to constrain and bound the error on your result. And the way it basically works is the intuition for it is that you're going to take each username and hash it. And conceptually, you're going to hash it a few different ways. And it's unlikely, you're going to assume that all of these hash functions are ideal. So let's say you log in Bryce and Connor logs in and under one of these hash functions your usernames collide. But it's unlikely they'll collide under all of them. This is one of the intuitions behind probabilistic counting. You're using hashing to get that bounded space.
来限制和约束结果中的误差。它的基本工作原理、直观理解是，你将获取每个用户名并对其进行哈希处理。从概念上讲，你会用几种不同的方式对其进行哈希。而且不大可能——你会假设所有这些哈希函数都是理想的。所以假设布莱斯登录了，康纳登录了，在其中一个哈希函数下，你们的用户名碰撞了。但它们不太可能在所有这些函数下都碰撞。这就是概率计数背后的直观理解之一。你正在使用哈希来获得那种有界的空间。
The way it works is actually by using the hash as a bit string. One of the insights is that if I'm just seeing random numbers go by i.e. ideal hashes when I've seen the odds that I will have seen a number ending in n zeros is correlated with the fact that I have seen two to the n numbers, right? So if I've seen two numbers only, odds are one of them will have ended with a zero. If I've seen four numbers, the odds are higher that one of them will have ended with two zeros, right?
它的工作原理实际上是将哈希用作位字符串（bit string）。其中的一个见解是，如果我只是看到随机数流过——即理想哈希——当我看到以 n 个零结尾的数字的几率时，这与我见过 2 的 n 次方个数字的事实相关，对吧？所以如果我只看过两个数字，其中一个以零结尾的几率是一半。如果我看过四个数字，其中一个以两个零结尾的几率更高，对吧？
If I've seen eight numbers, the odds are higher that one of them will have ended with three zeros. And so you keep track of effectively the longest string of trailing zeros that you've seen and this allows you to recover an estimate for the total number of logins that you've seen a unique logins this is you know i'm i'm simplifying greatly but that's the intuition yeah a lot of that that reminds me a lot of uh quantum computing uh techniques for solving uh uniqueness uh counting yeah yeah it's related to things like bloom filters um there's a similar algorithm called count min sketch um which allows you not only to sort of count the number of things you've seen but also remove things from from the set of things you've seen if you haven't
如果我看过八个数字，其中一个以三个零结尾的几率更高。因此，你要跟踪你见过的最长的尾随零字符串，这允许你恢复对你见过的登录总数的估计——唯一登录数——你知道的，我大大简化了，但这正是直观理解。是的，这让我想起了很多量子计算技术，用于解决唯一性计数问题——是的，是的，它类似于布隆过滤器（bloom filters）之类的东西——有一个类似的算法叫作 Count-Min Sketch，它不仅允许你计算你见过的事物数量，还允许你从你见过的事物集合中移除事物，如果你还没有这样做的话
because underneath the hood it's it's keeping effectively several hash tables and all of these functions, so there's another great talk I want to plug, which is I think from Strange Loop 2013, it's called Add All the Things. It's by, his first name is Avi, I think, I can't remember his last name. Avi Brandt.
因为在底层，它实际上保留了几个哈希表和所有这些函数，所以这里还有另一个我想强力推荐的精彩演讲，我想是来自 2013 年的 Strange Loop，它叫作“添加所有事物”（Add All the Things）。主讲人，他的名是阿维（Avi），我想，我记不清他的姓了。阿维·勃兰特（Avi Brandt）。
Can't believe you already have it in your list of talks in your spreadsheet. I'm almost positive you recommended this talk and I watched it, but unfortunately I lost. We're looking at afolio of Words, which long-time listeners will know is the spreadsheet that basically tracks Connor's entire life. It's weird. I mean, so I don't have it in the list,
真不敢相信你的电子表格里已经把这个演讲收录进去了。我几乎可以肯定你推荐过这个演讲，我也看过了，但不幸的是我弄丢了。我们正在看《词语集锦》（folio of Words），老听众都知道，这是一个基本上追踪了康纳一生的电子表格。这太诡异了。我的意思是，我没有把它列在列表里，
but I recently realized that a talk that I watched. There's a tab called Witticisms. Oh, yeah, yeah. I mean, he used to be an actor, and so I would write down things that I watched. There's a tab called Witticisms. Oh, yeah, yeah. I mean, you used to be an actor, and so I would write down things that are like... Whoa, whoa, whoa. Take a step back. Repeat what you just said? I used to be an actor, professional actor in my
但我最近意识到一个我看过的演讲。有一个标签叫作“妙语”（Witticisms）。哦，对，对。我的意思是，他曾经是一名演员，所以我会写下我看过的一些东西。有一个标签叫作“妙语”。哦，对，对。我的意思是，你曾经是一名演员，所以我会写下那些听起来像……哇，哇，哇。退后一步。重复你刚才说的话？我曾经是一名演员，在我年轻的时候是一名职业演员。
youth. What? You know this. You know this about me. No, I do not! Yeah, you said we gotta talk about it at some point. Oh, my God. Were you in things? I mean, it was professional local theater.
什么？你知道这个。关于我，你知道这个。不，我不知道！是的，你说过我们必须在某个时候聊聊这个。天哪。你演过什么东西吗？我的意思是，那是专业的地方剧院。
It was not Broadway or anything. We do have to talk about this more. People paid to come and see me. I was in a play called Lost in Yonkers, which was a movie. Connor, my mind is blown how did i not know this about you uh i don't know anyways the point is is that uh i when i would read things in books like uh flexibility of thought or palpable falsity or a jocular remark i like to write them down and then because they sound they they roll off the tongue. That's what Witticisms.
那不是百老汇或别的什么。我们确实得深入聊聊这个。人们花钱来看我演出。我曾出演过一部名为《求生之旅》（Lost in Yonkers）的戏剧，它后来成了一部电影。康纳，我惊呆了，我怎么会不知道关于你的这件事？——我不知道。无论如何，重点是——当我会在书里读到一些东西，比如“思维的灵活性”（flexibility of thought）、“表面上的虚假性”（palpable falsity）或“诙谐的言辞”（a jocular remark），我喜欢把它们记下来，然后因为它们听起来——它们朗朗上口。这就是妙语（Witticisms）。
Add All the Things is a talk that kindled my love of monoids. And in it, Avi Bryant talks about, he talks about a statistical framework for doing probabilistic things among other things and one of the points of the talk is that all of these things are monoids hyper log log in other words having a monoid is one of the keys to being able to distribute the computation right you can calculate you can you can split your logins load balance your logins and on on each separate machine, you can run this hyperloglog algorithm, and then you can combine the resulting data structures because they are monoidal. And you can get the same result as if it had been just one machine i'm almost positive you told me about this talk at the same time you told me about um yes is it called algebra twitters statistics framework algebra more birds yeah yeah yeah so i'm positive i watched it i just clearly didn't update my spreadsheet um yeah more birds birds
《添加所有事物》这个演讲点燃了我对幺半群（monoids）的热爱。在其中，阿维·勃兰特谈到了用于做概率事情的统计框架以及其他事情，演讲的要点之一是所有这些东西都是幺半群。HyperLogLog，换句话说，拥有幺半群是能够分布式计算的关键之一，对吧？你可以计算——你可以分割你的登录，对你的登录进行负载均衡，并且在每台单独的机器上，你可以运行这个 hyperloglog 算法，然后你可以组合所得的数据结构，因为它们是幺半群的。你可以得到与单台机器完全相同的结果。我几乎可以肯定你向我推荐这个演讲的同时，也向我推荐了——是的，它叫代数推特（algebra twitters）统计框架，代数更多小鸟——是的，所以我确信我看过它，我只是显然没有更新我的电子表格——是的，更多小鸟，小鸟
are everywhere we should probably start wrapping up because Bryce is getting tired, but I want to see what happens when we use a proper pseudorandom number sequence. Connor and I have to get in all the algorithm content
无处不在。我们大概应该开始收尾了，因为布莱斯累了，但我想看看当我们使用适当的伪随机数序列时会发生什么。康纳和我必须在 Quick Bench 内容结束之前把所有的算法内容都讲完。
by the end of the Quick Bench content. Because the Quick Bench content is keeping Bryce awake. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为 Quick Bench 的内容正在让布莱斯保持清醒。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。